[Music]
okay winds up guys mkbhd here so a
little while ago on Twitter I've started
a challenge with myself to use an iPad
as my only portable computer so for
about the past two weeks that's what
I've been doing so this has been
fascinating with the iPad you know it's
not very often that a software update
has such a huge effect on a relatively
new piece of tech you know sometimes
they'll boost the camera quality a
little bit or it'll smooth out some bugs
or give a little performance boost here
and there but iPad OS Seth that's come
out in this public beta form has really
transformed the iPad pro and a bunch of
ways should it have been this way in the
first place probably but you know here
we are so originally I thought I would
want to do this laptop replacement
challenge with the bigger 13 inch iPad
pro since it's closer to the size of the
laptop that I was already using but when
I installed that early iPad OS I put it
on my 11 inch iPad pro thinking I would
just take it back off but then I really
liked it and I kind of felt it was way
more portable and easy to use and type
on and I got really into it so now this
is my iPad pro of choice it's the 11
inch cellular iPad pro space grey half a
terabyte of storage and the iPad OS 13
public beta so basically the premise
behind all this is your ability to use
an iPad as your primary mobile computer
will depend on of course exactly what
you're doing
on your computer when you're mobile so
what do I needed to do over the past
couple weeks we've been shooting season
1 of retro tech which is super exciting
you guys probably saw the pilot episode
with the Game Boy
we're shooting season 1 so in between
shooting and traveling my computing
needs are actually relatively simple I
need to read emails and email people
back download and sign attachments do
social media that's pretty normal photo
editing watching videos publishing
videos and listening to music and that's
about it you know when I actually come
back into the studio for work I work on
the desktop on the iMac Pro on a real
computer but any time I leave I don't
take any laptop with me any time I'm
home I resist the urge to use any
desktop I'm all iPad pro all the time so
of course this has had it
pros and it's cons that's what this
video is about and I've been taking my
notes as this goes along so these are
those the main one the one that dictates
it all is the whole reason I wanted to
try this in the first place the iPad pro
is just more fun to use like I said this
in the full review and it's true
especially the smaller one I'm super
likely to take it out of my bag and just
use it when I can even over my phone in
the back of an uber for flipping through
emails or just web browsing just the
thinness the metal of the form factor
the light balanced weight 120 Hertz
display it's just fun we've been over
this by the way the iOS Gmail app has
this profile switcher that's just by
swiping up or down on the profile
picture Google please the Android
version needs this too just putting that
out there but anyway yeah it's fun to
use but the tough part about using an
iPad all the time is the ergonomics for
sure
so I'll carry it with no case no skin
and for me no keyboard folio or anything
just the naked iPad pro and I feel like
that's partially because I guess I'm
stubborn about cases I don't really
think there are any good cases or
keyboards that I like using for the iPad
but I also just want to appreciate the
impressive design of this thing and
covering it up with a cheap rubber
feeling case just feels wrong maybe it's
just me but of course the laptop has the
obvious ergonomic advantage of a hinge
if it's a good one
right so the keyboard at one angle and
the screen at another now with the iPad
the three main positions I found myself
using the iPad were holding it up with
two hands propping it with one hand and
poking with the other or lying it flat
on a table or in my lap just for typing
so luckily it's lightweight so holding
it up is actually pretty easy to do for
a long time that was the most common
position I found in the prop position
when you're resting it with one hand and
poking with the other was more common
with sometimes gaming or just like lazy
browsing and scrolling and then with the
emailing or writing a bunch for making
videos and things like that anything
that involves a keyboard for a longer
period of time I'll put it down on my
lap or a table and type away this is
easily the worst organ amah cos ition
for the ipad and that's when I miss a
laptop the most like typing over long
periods on an iPad screen with both
sizes no matter how you do it is not
anything quite like typing on a real
keyboard
and I've gotten used to it for brief
bursts but that's the downside I've had
apples keyboard folio cases for the iPad
for a while and you can you know sort of
prop it up like a laptop with the
magnets and then type on a silicon
keyboard and there's usually a lot of
wobble but I don't know I'm just not a
big fan of that so I always just default
to taking it off naked iPad and just
typing on glass oh and of course iPad OS
now has that pinched down smaller
keyboard so you can swipe type on the
side or drag that thing anywhere you
want if things are in a pinch pinch
I'm also way more likely to game on the
iPad pro than a MacBook Pro that's just
fact so here's another downside though
there's a couple of dongles needed to
sort of match the laptop some extra
things you carry with it so I keep the
naked iPad in the laptop sleeve in this
backpack so it's just sort of loose in
there but it's fine it uses the same USB
C charger as the laptop would but also
in the same sleeve I can toss an Apple
pencil a flash drive and an SD card
reader which sounds kind of fine but
then the laptop just kind of has a
little extra loose stuff hanging around
in it not a big deal I guess also if
anyone else wants to take on this
challenge I highly recommend like a
battery bank like this one so I've I've
linked this below and other what's in
that bag stuff in the past but it's
20,000 milliamp hours it's by Ankur it's
got fast charging USBC something like
this will back up the iPad multiple
times over now the iPad does have a plus
battery life like it's excellent even on
this LTE version it won't die in a full
day of use but if I ever get low I'll
just toss it on my backpack wall plugged
into the battery and then when I take it
out it's full again so I'll link all the
stuff I'm talking about below the like
button of course
but the biggest workflow difference I
found that it's enabled but that works
better now that the files app is
improved is photo editing so now I can
go from Canon EOS R to the SD card then
from the SD card to the SD card reader
so plugging that into the iPad then I
can use the new and improved files app
to go through the files tree of the SD
card to pick the exact raw file that I
want import that one file or multiple if
I want then hood over to Lightroom or
really whatever editor of choice
supports raw import the raw image and
then start editing which is usually
awesome with the
a pencil this is something I've had a
lot of fun with of course connecting via
USB type-c directly to a camera is an
even better workflow for certain cameras
so that's awesome but yeah overall the
iPad makes a fantastic mobile image
editor and just as good as a trackpad
so in summary using an iPad as your only
mobile computer has its ups and downs in
2019 so I found the good parts were the
awesome performance the great battery
life and just the fun form factor we
already know the iPad is fun to use Plus
having LTE everywhere was a nice bonus
the desktop class browser is excellent
the desktop feeling files app is a great
improvement and there's a download
manager in Safari that also ties it all
together beautifully and then editing
photos with the Apple pencil is dope and
then the pain points the downsides were
mostly typing and ergonomics so anytime
you need to reply to an email with a lot
of text or just a lot of typing or
writing on this glass screen or if you
don't like the keyboard case that has
the keyboard built-in it's just not as
good and then there is a solid learning
curve to all the new multitasking
gestures in iPad OS I went over all of
them in this video if you want to check
it out and then some of them are pretty
useful but there are so many extra
things that I didn't really use most of
them and in my opinion there still isn't
really a great solid non wobbling
keyboard case for the iPad pro
sadly and then also something I never
really did is video editing so I've
stopped like I said I stopped video
editing on the go because red footage is
really heavy
laptops can barely keep up so I just
don't do that I bring it to the desktop
but if you don't shoot red or if you
have you know 1080p footage or something
like that and you have simple video
editing to do it's possible there are
solutions there's Adobe Premiere rush
there is luma fusion there's iMovie and
other youtubers much braver than me have
taken the dive and and mess with video
editing on the iPad pro so I'll leave a
Tod video for example link below for
that I'm not that guy but if you are
that guy you can also do video editing
so iPad pro with iPad OS beta feels the
closest to not a computer replacement
but a computer alternative more than
anything else I've used lately with all
that being said
I am still really excited for the new
rumored 60 inch MacBook Pro like a lot
of this really just comes down to what
you really enjoy using so I happen to
love using the iPad pro so I wanted to
see what it would be like using it all
the time but if you have a laptop that
you really love using then that changes
all of that
who knows maybe with Johnny I've not
designing Apple products anymore we'll
get these crazy radical new Apple laptop
designs in the next year or two I don't
even really know fingers crossed we'll
see some good stuff hopefully worthy of
the pro in the name but only time will
tell
we'll see until the next one thanks for
watching catch you guys later
days